ah
[Música]
en alemán ya está en curso lo que el
ministerio de finanzas describió en mayo
como el paquete de ayuda más grande en
la historia de este país un paquete para
luchar contra el coronavirus y que tiene
tres áreas clave tres metas muy
importantes proteger la salud pública
apoyar a las empresas y mantener la
cohesión social es un paquete de ayuda
que según explicó en mayo el diario
económico handelsblatt equivale al 34
por ciento del producto interno bruto de
alemania además es un paquete que tiene
un elemento político muy importante en
este país entre otros aspectos porque
alemania tan reacio a incurrir en
desequilibrios fiscales aceptó nuevas
deudas como parte de este proyecto es un
paquete de ayuda que responde como bien
dijeron las autoridades alemanas a
desafíos sin precedentes que está
causando el coronavirus
[Música]
marruecos decretó el estado de
emergencia sanitaria en marzo y desde la
fecha existe un fondo económico para
paliar la crisis generada por la
pandemia a este fondo fue creado por el
rey mohamed el sexto y dotado
inicialmente de unos mil millones de
dólares pero a día de hoy no existe
ningún sitio público de información
continua y actualizada sobre los gastos
y los ingresos según el ministro de
economía y finanzas mohamed bien se
abona los ingresos habrían alcanzado los
tres mil millones de dólares entre
donaciones públicas y privadas y se
habrían gastado unos dos mil quinientos
millones en la adquisición de material
médico y en el apoyo a empresas y a la
caja nacional de la seguridad social y a
falta de transparencia cabe destacar que
más de seis millones de personas se han
quedado sin trabajo y según los datos
oficiales son a menos de 1 millón las
declaradas en la caja nacional de la
seguridad social es se calcula que más
de 5 millones de familias que dependen
de la economía informal se encuentran en
situación de paro y pobreza
[Música]
según cifras oficiales no actualizadas
completamente el gobierno chileno habría
dedicado alrededor del 12 por ciento del
producto interior bruto a fondos para
luchar contra la pandemia del colon a
virus en el país esto a través de un
primer programa en el inicio de la
pandemia que consideraba una inversión
de 11 mil 700 millones de dólares
histórica y que fue destinada entre
otros programas al bono kobe al ingreso
de emergencia familiar ayudas a la clase
media y trabajadores independientes
además de eso en los últimos días el
presidente sebastián piñera lanzó un
programa de reactivación de la economía
que contempla una inversión de 34 mil
millones de dólares en obras públicas y
que tratará de crear 250 mil empleos a
los que habría que añadir iniciativas
privadas que podrían alcanzar otros 115
mil empleos adicionales eso en un país
que ha perdido 18 millones de empleos
desde comienzos del año hay que tener en
cuenta el efecto del estallido social
también y donde más de 700 mil se
encuentran suspendidos por efecto de la
pandemia
[Música]